La volta al món a peu, dia 283.
Us vaig dir que volia sortir a les 6 i mitja, no?
Doncs bé, són les 8 i quart.
Bé, tu, és que m'han servit l'esmorzar, hi ha uns ous fregits,
jo també estava cansat, tenia son, volia carregar la bateria...
En fi, farem el que podem avui.
Tothom ja està en moviment, el sol ja està ben alt,
anem a caminar 50 quilòmetres, podré fer avui?
No ho sé, ho dubto. Provem-ho.
Avui és dimarts 8 de setembre
i mireu, demostració gràfica del tema de la temperatura.
Ara vaig en màniga curta, 8 i pico del matí,
però els vessals estan congelats.
Clar, aquesta nit haurem baixat als menos 2, menos 4, menos 5,
a saber, i estan congelats.
Bueno, males notícies, soc burro,
i no vaig carregar la bateria ahir, perquè vaig dir, bueno,
la carrego avui, aquest matí, perquè es carrega ràpid i ja està.
No, l'he carregat aquest matí, ho he intentat,
però suposo que el voltatge que tenen aquí
deu ser baix o el que sigui,
i l'he deixat enxufat d'una hora i pico, i no.
M'ha pujat un 5-6%.
Llavors, bueno, doncs res,
haurem de confiar en la placa solar,
que la vaig provar abans d'ahir,
que em vau veure la placa solar el dia de la taparreina,
i no vaig comptar-ho molt bé,
però la veritat és que tot el dia hi va carregar,
del 30 al 100%.
Esperem que sigui una càrrega real,
i no fake, i funcioni.
Perquè si no, bueno, si no us quedeu sense vídeo,
simplement, no és que jo em caigui sense bateria,
però hauré de gravar menys.
I bé, la previsió l'ha encertat,
perquè mireu quin dia que fa avui,
ni un núvol, zero vent,
el contrast amb el dia d'ahir, bestial.
Que aguante, que aguante.
Que guante.
Fins demà!
Bé, jo dic alemany, que és el típic.
Avui dia?
Sí, dormim a Morgab.
És bo.
És bo?
O és el que és.
Bé, doncs, adeu!
Adeu.
Però ara som motos, eh?
Per cert,
ahir us vaig dir que la gent d'aquí
tenia unes faccions diferents,
de veritat,
que semblaven com això
de Mongòlia o de Xina.
Bé, doncs avui al menjador
he vist que una de les portes tenia aquest símbol.
És la bandera de Kirguistán.
I llavors els he preguntat,
escolta, això?
Sou de Kirguistán o què? I em diu sí.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Ja no els he preguntat què fan aquí i tal,
però ja m'estranyava a mi.
Són de Kirguistán i estan aquí.
A Alichur. No sé molt bé per què.
Però bé, es veu que es guanyen bé la vida
amb el lloc aquell de l'hostal.
La una i mitja,
la mitja,
25,
25 quilòmetres i gairebé 5 hores de marxa.
Si avui volgués fer
els 50,
doncs aniria per la meitat.
Si fem uns càlculs ràpids,
li sumes a una i mitja
5 quilòmetres hora, que és el que vaig,
doncs 25 quilòmetres més,
serien 5 hores més,
per tant, acabaria a les 6 i mitja,
que és l'hora que se'n va el sol,
per tant seria perfecte.
Però això,
tenint en compte que no
faig cap descans.
I ara necessito un descans.
I vaig a seure una estona aquí.
Bé, no sé, estaré molt refugiat del vent,
però, no sé, a més, menjaré alguna cosa i tal.
Actualització a les 3 de la tarda.
Estic, estic bastant mental boom, eh?
Estic, m'està costant molt psicològicament
el dia d'avui, perquè és que és tot igual.
I és recte, recte, recte, recte,
recte, aburrit.
Sí, vaig escoltant la ràdio,
poso música, però...
No, van passant els quilòmetres,
però passen lents i lents.
Ja ho sabia, això, eh?
Com vaig venir aquí.
Ja ho sabia.
I mira, avui, fa millor dia que ahir,
el vent el tinc darrere, és a dir, m'empeny.
No fa tant de vent, encara que fa una mica de vent.
Però igualment és dur, eh?
Igualment és, és dur.
Com no fa calor, doncs no estic gastant aigua.
I encara tinc, he sortit amb un litre,
i no sé quan em queda, però encara en tinc.
Home, abans d'acampar hauré de demanar,
perquè si no em quedaré sense, però...
No cal, no cal beure molt.
Ostres, que bé, tu!
Just 5 minuts després de gravar l'últim vídeo,
passa aquesta furgoneta, para,
i resulta que són dos polacs, i em diuen
que necessites aigua.
I jo, sí, vinga, fot-li.
He tret l'ampolla, encara tenia mitja ampolla,
però bueno, he begut tot el que he pogut,
i me l'han omplert d'aigua de garrafa,
no d'aigua de merda de Tadjikistan.
Perdó per la paraula, eh?
Sí, que a tu, molt bé, ja està.
Jo crec que potser per avui ja tinc, eh?
Bueno, us en recordeu el primer dia
que un home em va convidar al seu restaurant,
bueno, a un restaurant a dormir?
Doncs me l'he trobat aquí.
What was your name again? I forgot.
Sojournar.
Well, it's been more than one month,
but I manage.
I'm, I think, four days away from China.
What are you doing here?
I'm taking here tourists.
How do you like Pamir?
Very well, very, absolutely great.
It's great, but for walking it's hard.
Yeah, yeah, of course.
I wish you all the best in your walking.
Thank you.
No, no, thank to you, thank to you.
You're watching my videos, eh?
Of course, every day.
Molt loco, tio.
Well, it's been amazing to find you, eh?
You're going to Murghab, right?
Yeah, of course.
Maybe we'll see each other there.
I arrive tomorrow.
Yeah, of course.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Thank you very much. Adeu.
Actualitzaciós són les quatre.
Molt loco, tio.
Us en recordeu, no?, d'aquest home?
Potser no vaig ensenyar la seva cara, d'aquí penso.
Sí, sí, vaig dormir a un restaurant, allà.
Boníssim.
Mira, això m'ha pujat els ànims, tu.
Actualització a les cinc de la tarda.
Aquí, caminant.
Dia molt llarg, es fa molt llarg, eh?
He de dir que la placa celular està funcionant.
Eh...
He sortit que tenia la placa...
Bueno, he carregat el mòbil, tal, la tenia a 30 i pico, o 60 i pico, no recordo.
L'he descarregat una estona, no he comptat.
Ha pujat el 100, ha carregat tot.
He tornat a carregar el mòbil, ara l'he tornat a posar.
Per tant, sembla que guai.
A veure, aquí us deixo un enllaç.
Per si la voleu comprar, és de l'Express.
També la descripció del vídeo.
Recordeu que jo m'he hagut de comprar una bateria, entre cometes, dolenta, de 10.000,
per poder-la fer servir, perquè amb la de 20.000 pepina...
no anava, vale?
Llavors, bueno, tindre-ho en compte.
Però bueno, és molt lleugera i barata.
Per tant, crec que val la pena intentar-ho.
Si sou amants del senderisme.
Les 6 de la tarda,
el tema de la posta de sol és un escàndol.
Cada dia perdo 5 minuts, sense exagerar.
O sigui, fa dos dies, s'anava a 34.
Ara, a 27, crec.
En fi, com veieu, ja vaig amb la jaqueta i els guants,
que els tinc en la butxaca perquè els he tret.
Ja fa rasca. Estic als 4.000 metres.
Vull dir que ja pot fer rasca.
Bueno, a veure fins quan segueixo.
Les 7.12, 50,47 km, una animalada.
Bueno, per què he caminat tant?
Doncs perquè el mapi, avui no és l'Ajo Berlanda, és el mapi,
diu que allà, no es veu, hi ha la icona de refugi.
Però especifica que és parets sense sostre.
Però bueno, tu, només que estigui...
doncs una mica protegit del vent, ja en val la pena.
Ara estic a la Pamir.
La highway, la carretera, doncs em desvio.
I són uns 200 metres cap allà.
No veig absolutament res.
Bueno, amb l'afrontal sí, eh.
A veure com és el lloc.
Doncs estic aquí.
I no hi ha absolutament res.
Ni walls, ni roof, ni res.
Res, res, res. Bueno.
Venim per aquí. Era molt pla.
I no feia vent perquè aquestes muntanyes d'aquí,
que suposo que no es veuen,
parapeten el vent.
Llavors doncs simplement em posaré aquí.
A aquesta esplanada i ja està.
No, a veure, és un bon lloc.
També he de dir que avui no fa massa vent, eh.
Vull dir, jo a la Pamir m'havia acompat uns vents,
m'havia acompat quatre piquetes, us en recordeu?
Uf, jo no puc ni parlar.
Doncs ni falta agafant, eh, quan venim avui.
Resto. Molt bé.
Doncs planto, em fico dintre la tenda, menjo i fem resum.
51 quilòmetres avui.
Dos cafès, cap refresc i zero euros gastats.
Uf, duríssim, eh.
Dia...
Duríssim, duríssim, duríssim.
I demà queden...
Queden cinquanta...
sis, no, cinquanta-quatre, cinquanta-tres quilòmetres fins a Murgap.
He decidit que demà no faré vídeo.
No, perquè al final què serà el vídeo?
Serà igual que avui.
Carretera, monotonia, pam-pam-pam, cansadíssim.
I mira, si no faig el vídeo com a mínim em trec un...
un pes mental de sobre, no?
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
A veure, demà en tauria m'aixecaré més d'hora.
Llavors, en principi hauré d'arribar abans,
no hauré d'apurar tant...
tant...
Estic content d'haver fet el cinquanta perquè havia començat tard, eh.
Sí, sí, sí.
Ara mateix no fa fred, no fa aire,
però estic als 4.100 metres sobre el nivell del mar.
Jo crec que...
la nit serà freda.
Bueno, llavors, ja que demà no hi haurà vídeo,
faré alguna cosa per Insta.
Ja us ho explico.
Clar, quan arribi a Murgap
ve el segon tram que us vaig dir l'altre dia, no?
De Murgap fins la Xina.
També són cent quilòmetres.
O 90 i pico.
Però no faré, com he fet aquesta vegada, de dividir-ho en dos dies.
Perquè si divideixo en dos dies,
el segon dia arribaria a la frontera tard.
Arribaria a la frontera a l'hora de fer-se fosc.
I a la frontera serà d'arribar d'hora.
Per tant, el que faré
en principi serà,
demà passat, començar a caminar tard.
Tipo, descansar bé.
A Murgap, a un hotel,
poder descansar bé. I començar a caminar
a la una, a les dos.
Fer 20 quilòmetres, acampar.
El dia següent fer 40 i pico fins a
una parada de camioners
que també et deixen dormir allà.
Dormir allà. I l'últim dia,
és a dir, d'aquí,
sense comptar avui, d'aquí quatre dies,
fer els últims 27 quilòmetres fins a
Culmapàs. Són molts quilòmetres.
Prefereiria acampar,
o sigui, estar més a prop. Però bé, el fet que hi hagi
el tema aquest de la parada
de camioners, doncs, pararé allà.
Però bé, això ja no ho he explicat.
Però sí, hi haurà vídeo
demà passat.
Vinga, bona nit.
Fins demà!